hello everyone I hope you had a great
day as much of a great day as I had I
mean this is my first CSS comp which I
guess makes sense because this is the
first CSS cough here but actually I I
was at dais comp us and I didn't go to
CSS comp us and I heard so many good
things about it that I knew that when I
was coming over here again to another
Jay s coma that I would want to come to
CSS comps so I'm actually really honored
that I got a chance to speak and that I
got a chance to talk to you guys today
about the future of CSS so the title of
my talk is CSS levels up and I searched
really really long and hard for just the
right video game shift that I could
throw in here and I just couldn't make
up my mind in the end it really really
was disappointing so just pretend in
your head right now that the Final
Fantasy victory theme is playing and
anyway okay so that was only funny to me
but um so anyway as Jen said my name is
Angelina Favreau I work for Mozilla and
I work on the Firefox operating system I
am what's called the Technical
Evangelist which I believe is a little
bit of a misleading term I think people
assume when they hear the term
Evangelist that that means that we like
the people on my team just kind of go
around and just give talks like this
right now but that's actually only a
small fraction of what we do most of the
time I'm actually interacting with
developers like you and looking at your
code and helping you get your apps ready
for the marketplace I spend some time
coding tools to help developers like
right now I'm working on a Ruby module
that does JWT verification for in-app
payments and sometimes we do like
workshops for example for a Firefox OS
so I do a lot of developer education as
well so if anybody's interested in
Firefox OS and you think you want to
know what skills you need to which work
on that you can come find me at the
after party tonight and I'll be happy to
talk shop with you about that but for
now we're going to talk about CSS so
anyway last year I gave a talk at Jess
Kampf on shadow DOM and we've had lots
and lots of talks since then on web
components which makes me really excited
because one of my favorite things and
when I dove into that topic I actually
knew nothing
about it so what happened was is a few
people said to me Angelina you know
you're good at you know communicating
information and we think that you should
submit some talk proposals at some point
and I was totally terrified and I told
myself like okay you know what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna pick a topic that I know a
little bit about and I think it's kind
of interesting and I'm gonna submit it
and like probably it's not gonna get
picked and then lo and behold a couple
months later somebody's like guess what
you're gonna talk at Jas comp I'm like
that's great
oh boy so I mean I knew what you know
shadow Dom was it wasn't totally blind
but the first thing I did was I dove
into the w3c documents and learned
everything I possibly could about all of
the web components stuff I basically
read those specs inside out more times
than I want to even tell you because
that was a lot of my Friday nights for a
while and I sort of became this armchair
w3c spec participant and what that means
is that I participate on some of the w3c
lists that are public and you can join
them I look on most of them because I
only really say something when I think I
have you know something valuable to say
and I've thought about it a lot
and one day I would actually like to be
someone writing those specs so that's
part of why I participate there and I
mean why do I do this
so earlier when Nicole gave her keynote
she said oh I've you know I've read some
of the specs and I don't want everyone
to have to and then I was sitting with
Jed and he and I were catching up
because he wanted to know about like
introducing me and like you know whether
he could say embarrassing things or not
and he and he was like asking me about
what I was going to talk about and I
mentioned that I would talk a little bit
today about w3c process so that people
understand how CSS features come into
being and I told them that one day I
would like to work more on w3c specs he
was like why would you want to do that
so I want I want to shape the web right
like the web is where I grew up I I
think the first thing I did on the web
when I was I don't know how old was I
remember was IRC and I remember being on
the web and I remember building websites
with lots of animated gifs
I still do that basically and I followed
the w3c stuff because I want to
understand what is coming I always want
to be on that bleeding edge much like
you guys I find new things shiny and
exciting
and on top of that I want to be able to
teach developers what is coming because
those specification documents are very
very dry sometimes and I'll explain why
that is but first let's talk about a
little bit of a brief history of CSS I
think in our industry that we have a
little bit of a terminology problem
and actually not just a single
terminology problem but like a number of
them so for example when someone asks me
you know what is web components are what
are web components I'm like well web
components is actually a little hat for
several sets of technologies like shadow
DOM HTML imports
you know maybe decorators those are
weird to me still and templates and
stuff like that so web components
doesn't refer to any single one of those
things those are all the technologies
that enables that who here knows what
html5 is right like we've you've been
using the term html5 to describe a set
of technologies as well when you see
that in some like you know HR person has
put it on you know like a job posting
somewhere you know that html5 means HTML
probably to the you know Loveleen a
level five specification or version 5s
specification but it also includes
JavaScript and usually includes you know
level three CSS modules
it doesn't just refer to html5 and so
CSS has a little bit of a terminology
problem now the first version of CSS one
was the first spec was published in 1996
and included some core things like font
properties text attributes and alignment
color of text backgrounds margin border
padding positioning like basically the
basics right and then CSS to that level
sped the let CSS two level spec was
published in 1998 a superset of CSS one
we got more positioning stuff like
absolute relative fixed and z-index we
are aural style sheets bi-directional
text support media types and then people
kind of thought long and hard about CSS
too and decided a lot of it was all
wrong and they sort of bumped it up and
it became CSS 2.1 this finally became a
recommendation in 2011 it fix stuff by
removing poorly implemented features
from you know CSS one and two
it was iterated and tweaked for a long
time because yeah it's inception and all
that was you know
before 2011 2011 was when it sort of got
like you know the big thumbs up but
basically it was a more solid and
carefully defined specification and then
we came to css3 right let that's part of
the the little hat that is html5 but
it's not actually a version of CSS which
is pretty interesting because everybody
refers to css3 as like you know version
3 of CSS this is when CSS it was
actually factored into various modules
and the earliest module drafts were in
1999 and CSS had so many groups of
features they were split into modules
just to make development of each set of
features a lot easier rather than just
put everything under one hat by June
2012 there were over 50 modules so when
you think about that scale it makes a
little bit sense to sort of
compartmentalize them and modularize
them a little bit and arguably some say
css3 is a monolithic version but in
practice and if you look at the docs
css3 or perme that the advent of css3
was when the maintainer x' decided that
we're not going to actually have like a
css3 version but modules themselves will
sort of be individually versioned with
like this leveling system which I tell
you just reminds me of video games and
so in css3 level level 3 modules of
things like media queries namespaces
selectors level 3 and color have
official recommendations and I'll talk a
little bit about like what these
recommendations mean in a moment so CSS
for this is a blog post by a gentleman
named tab Atkins and tab is a fantastic
contributor to the w3c specifications he
does a lot of work he's a main editor on
many of them a very smart guy and he
wrote this this blog post and he
regularly gets people asking him so when
is CSS for coming and he's like there's
no such thing there never will be a
thing we're do things by modules now and
it was very funny that when my talk was
announced for you know this conference
somebody started tweeting they're like
well you do know that there is no CSS
for right and I'm like yeah no I know
that thanks did you read the talk
description about terminology problems
but there's always people like that so
CSS for anyway the CSS for level 4
modules are so fresh that I don't
actually know the dates of when most of
them had inception like that
that knew and they level independently
just like the css3 ones CSS four is not
a monolithic version so you know people
would argue that you shouldn't call it
just CSS four but rather refer to the
status of each module individually but
[ __ ] it just call the collection of CSS
4 module CSS for you know that even
though we have this conversation people
are still going to refer to as CSS 4
come on right like HTML 5 came to mean
like JavaScript and CSS 2 it's just I
surrender to it and I don't know if
other people are gonna get angry but I
just say call it CSS 4 and and just be
really specific about the module if
someone wants to be picky about that so
let's talk a little bit about where CSS
comes from I'm talking about like this
w3c process and these these modules
having various levels well you guys are
probably familiar with who the w3c are
does anybody here not know who w3c is no
hands okay cool I thought there might be
one or two but you know you can never
really tell the the level of expertise
of the audience and apparently you guys
are awesome
so the w3c working groups spec browser
tech out and the CSS working group spec
CSS Oh makes sense so how does an idea
become a feature and what exactly is a
specification in this context so
specifications like I mentioned are
particularly dry documents and that's
because specifications are not written
for you the users they're actually
written for the implementers the people
who are writing the code that makes the
user agent the browser that you're using
and it defines very carefully how the
browser implementers should you know
implement those features so that we
don't have as many headaches with things
like cross browser compatibility and so
that they are as to say interoperable so
it's not a user manual it's really for
the programmers that are implementing
the materials but that being said you
can learn a lot from reading these
specifications you can learn basically
what the future of the language features
are for CSS so the first thing that
happens is well ideas and did you know
that there was once a spec called
JavaScript style sheets yeah so this was
apparently a thing I just learned this a
short while ago it was only ever
implemented in Netscape 4x there were no
selectors you would just modify
properties of the document tags object
and so you would get something
this and you can see that you're
modifying like tags h1 color equals blue
that would change all of the h1s in a
document to blue and all of this
interestingly enough is inside of a
style Tet or sorry a style tag but it's
style type text/javascript which is
pretty interesting to me anyway that
totally was nixed but you also remember
that scroll bar thing that I II did it
was only ever implemented in Internet
Explorer circa 5.5 this one didn't
actually I think really ever have a spec
like the jss s1 did this was just
something like I use like hey wouldn't
it be great if users could change the
default scroll bar on the window and so
you got stuff like this I'm sorry if
this is a little bit small but you were
able to specify like scroll bar
highlight color scroll bar face color
and this was the point for me that when
I was getting really into web
development I thought this was the
coolest thing of course you know me
being like how old was I like 12 or 13
or something like that and I didn't
understand like why this would be a
problem for accessibility usability I
just thought grad I can put colors
everywhere and so you know there it is
in action in Internet Explorer so that
was like a very vendor specific thing
that did not become a feature so I mean
it starts with ideas and not all ideas
are good ideas right but sometimes good
ideas make it into what's called a
working draft and the working draft is a
snapshot of the current state of
discussion around a set of features at
this point with a working draft you can
go to the working draft you can see what
the reflection of what people are
talking about on the w3c lists and it's
sort of a codified document of the
things that people have been able to
agree upon and not always agreed upon
either if you go through the documents
to find little green areas about like
hey this is good you'll find little red
areas like hey maybe we should add an
example here or this is a problem
because of this other feature or
something like that
and at this particular stage with
working drafts the w3c also solicits for
user input so for anything that you find
in the w3c that that you think is very
interesting and has a working draft you
can jump on that list and you can
contribute to that discussion and so at
this point anything that's a feature in
working draft stage is unstable and
incomplete so after people have bickered
a lot on the internet as one one tends
to do the
can graph we'll move into a stage called
last call and that is when the working
group expresses that the draft is
basically complete and all of the major
issues and problems with it are resolved
and that is sort of your last chance to
bring like major issues in the
discussion like oh no if we implement
this in a certain way the earth will
explode and hopefully you've resolved
that issue so that the earth will not
explode when you try and load your web
page in your browser after that we move
to candidate recommendation and this is
actually the most important step for you
the users because this is the step where
the group is expressing that all the
issues are resolved and not only that
but you actually want to move into
implementation this is when browsers can
actually you know browser vendors can
actually say ok shadow dom or you know
CSS variables now we're going to start
putting this into the browser and users
are going to start testing it so they
actually start to implementation then we
moved on to proposed recommendation by
this point and after testing these
features in the browser for a while
there should be a comprehensive test
suite develop and the implementation
should be in at least two major browsers
pardon me there should be at least two
shipping implementations which sort of
implies major browsers so for example if
say Chrome and Firefox or Firefox and
opera or Safari and you know some pair
of browsers has implemented those
features probably with some iteration
and feedback we might want to move that
spec to a proposed recommendation and
the w3c members will generally review
things at that point and you might think
that we're done after proposed
recommendation but no no there's more
bureaucracy to go so then we go to
recommendation that is the final stage
there's no more recommendations after
that this is where we say ok we think
that this document that describes how
this feature should be implementing the
browser is good we're done with it at
this point there's nothing else done
except for some time there's some errata
that's amended but it's also important
to note that even though something
becomes a recommendation it can also
become obsolete by another piece of
technology or another recommendation and
this process is nonlinear for example
right now CSS level 3 selectors are
being developed alongside CSS level 4
selectors and many cs3 or css3 level
modules CSS level 3 particles
are actually like they're not near their
recommendation status they're nowhere
near complete some of them haven't even
been implemented yet so that being said
that now that you understand how
features are made and you know that
there are some CSS level 3 modules that
are still percolating I can tell you
that there's actually some CSS level 4
modules and so if we have like sort of
like a timeline or not a timeline of
like you know how far in the future
things are and like you've got you've
got like CSS 1 & 2 are all really solid
and like CSS 3s may be right here
because like some of the modules are
starting to be stamped you know
standardized and put into browsers CSS 4
is way out here so the stuff that I'm
going to talk to you about today is
stuff that I've gone to the
specification documents and I've pulled
out there they're interesting things
that I thought were cool to share but I
wanted to look ahead a little bit
further and so my warning to you is that
all this stuff is a work in progress so
you can actually go and take a look at
these documents you can go to the lists
and give feedback if you think that
they're cool ideas or if you think the
ridiculous idea is like it's okay to say
like well that's ridiculous it can and
will change and it will change Lots so
super future level 4 specs there is the
borders and backgrounds level 4 module
and there's some really cool things in
there for example in addition to your
border radius we're going to have
something called corner shape we'll be
able to describe a curve a convex curve
at the corner a bevel a diagonal slice
at the corner scoop a concave curve at
the corner and a notch which is a
concave rectangular notch at the corner
and officially I don't have photos of
this because there weren't any examples
in the spec so you have to use your
imagination and I think that this is
particularly interesting especially if
you've seen some of the stuff that Leah
vero has done with her border-radius
talk that she gave it a CSS comp in the
u.s. like the the other CSS comps and I
think that there's some really cool
opportunity there to combine things you
can do with border-radius having
additional shapes that you can do with
them with your borders now so there's
that and then we've got something called
border clip which I find a little bit a
little bit ridiculous but in a good way
and so a border clip sometimes you want
to hide parts of abort
maybe you do maybe you don't I mean I
actually hadn't thought about it before
I saw a border clip and then I thought
that it could be a really interesting
really interesting for people that
create art in the browser and use only
CSS so it's a set of properties border
cliff top right bottom border clip left
and of course naturally just using the
border border : as a shorthand property
will work like you would expect other
properties to and it when you're
specifying your units you can also use a
fraction or FR fractional unit which is
a unit specified by the css3
specification or sorry css3 grid
specification and a fractional unit is
described as one sheriff space in all
the available space of an element so
it's sort of a relative unit and i'm not
totally 100% sure if that one's going to
stay as a fractional units i also was
reading about one called like a gr like
a like a grid unit so that that's a bit
ambiguous but for our intents and
purposes we can refer to this relative
fractional unit for describing this but
so here's an example we have at the top
there we've described a border that's
thin solid black so it would go all the
way around the box and then what we've
done with border clip is we've said that
for one fractional unit and because only
one is specified that means the entire
element we're just going to say that the
border is clipped entirely so as the
comment says that would hide the border
and then what we do is we say border
clip top we want to show exactly ten
picks up ten pixels of the black border
then fill in one fractional unit and
then ten pixels and that one fractional
unit basically fills up all the
remaining space except for the twenty
pixels of that we've specified that we
actually want to show and so we've done
the same on the top and on the bottom an
example 35 the second one there we've
sort of done the same thing again we've
got border tops in solid black border
bottom thin solid black and we didn't do
anything to hide the borders here but
instead we just specified that we want
to clip the top and the boredom bottom
after the ten pixels
only ten pixels you end up with just a
little bit of a line but you can do more
interesting things with this so in this
example here we've defined a four pixel
farming four pixel border that's also
black but then we've used the fractional
units to actually describe the border
itself and use the like the absolute the
pixel units to describe the space
between those fractional units and so
you get something like this and so the
length of these border border parts will
change when the width of the element
changes so you can imagine like you know
like expanding this expanding this and
some sort of like a responsive layout
maybe and then it will change
accordingly so and as it mentions there
the read there is just for illustrative
purposes it says there that you know the
browser shouldn't implement them in red
that's how specific these documents are
but I thought this was particularly
interesting I think that for people that
you know spend a lot of time in CSS you
could do some creative things with this
and also imagine combining it with like
the the different border or partly the
different corner shapes as well you can
come up with some very interesting Lee
shaped divs no longer are you limited to
boxes I think we saw from the CSS
animations and stuff and the geometry
earlier that that's definitely not the
case today but this opens up the door
for more things so media queries level
for this is one that I really like
actually so there are a lot of devices
now that have ambient light sensors and
what level for media queries introduces
is luminosity and luminosity will allow
you to apply styles for specific
lighting conditions as reflected by the
ambient light sensor on your device
so you can specify for dim and dim would
be used for you know like nighttime you
know there's not very much light and so
so in that case high contrast styles
would probably be fairly distracting
also for normal you know whatever that's
going to mean but that's ideally
described as the environment where the
luminosity is ideal for reading and and
it's the ideal arrange for the screen
that you have and then also washed which
is of course the high the the brightest
end of things maybe you're reading on a
device in the sunlight and of course
that washes everything out so maybe you
do want high contrast in that situation
now I think all of this is very
interesting and of course like I say
this is well into the future but you
know devices with a light sensor usually
sort of auto adjust and it's going to be
a little bit hard I think to make
assumptions across devices about like
what a good baseline is but I think the
good news is that people are thinking
about this because I really don't like
it when like my I've got an iPhone and I
also have a Firefox OS device and they
both have ambient light sensors and they
both behave differently and I'm just
like well
that tells me this is going to be really
hard to standardize but also I like the
idea of doing something to compensate
for that change I think that's actually
something that we should be thinking
about so oh here just sorry here's an
example of luminosity so for example we
could have a media query for a normal
luminosity and then maybe we have like
specific color of text for that
obviously when adjusted for you know the
dim and then the washed as well so the
image values and replace content module
for level 4 namely this is the one that
I found interesting from this is
actually image set so I mean how many
people here have had to deal with
multiple sets of of assets for things
like retina display and for various
resolutions like basically everybody
right like people are already putting up
their hands so this is allows you to
specify an image set and and after
specifying the image set the user agent
the browser will refer to this image set
and figure out for you what the best
assets are to download for that user
agent with that resolution it's sort of
like takes care of some of that logic
for you which i think is a really good
move forward especially for the
responsive web ok so this one this one I
find kind of amazing so this one here is
is it says element but this is under the
image specification and this is where
you're able to use an HTML element as an
image so you take yes yes I know hold
onto your pants' okay so I think I
should crack the champagne for this one
because this is kind of my favorite
because I don't even really know what I
would use it for yet but that means that
there's someone out there that will use
it for something just that's going to
blow my mind in any case so how it works
is is you've got element it takes an ID
selector and in this silly example here
the paragraph element has been reused as
a background elsewhere in the document
so you can see you've got a source
element that's you know got a line
background with some white text and
you've got like the destination where
that element is going to be reused as an
image and there it is sort of like
patterned around there so I can imagine
like some situations where someone
creates kind of like a you know like a
CSS sprite but made only of CSS and then
once it's rendered they could then reuse
that to make some pretty creative
patterns so even though at first glance
like this is a really silly example I
think that that sort of
this has some potential as well so
anyway the last one is CSS selectors
level 4 so CSS selectors level 4
actually is probably the one that's been
getting the most attention it's the
first along because it adds like some
selectors that people have been really
wanting for a while and as some
functionality that you already find in a
lot of pre processors so I feel like you
know the specification is sort of
playing catch-up and that pre processors
have done like a really excellent job of
forging the way with what we'd call like
what we sometimes call like a prolly
fill like sometimes you refer to like a
polyfill that is like some you know like
some code that helps fill a feature that
a browser hasn't implemented but there's
a specification for some I would almost
look at the things that pre processors
have done as Frawley fills which is they
went ahead and implemented stuff like
CSS variables and and other sort of
logic Contin Combinator's and stuff like
that and by implementing those and
showing that there's demand for it that
can also inform like the direction that
specifications go as well so I haven't
like the CSS selectors level for is
worth worth definitely worth a read I've
only picked like a few of the ones that
I thought are useful and also in the
interest of time so one of them is the
one of them is matches so in this
particular example like compare the top
example where I've specified on each
line you know the anchor tag link the
hover the visited the focused and then
I've given them
text-decoration:underline with matches
I'm able to specify them and just just
add much tidier lists
and I rather like that notation I think
that that's pretty fantastic and also I
can imagine a situation where I have a
div that's a header and a footer and I
just want to change the text color for
those I might do that in that way so I
think that matches has a lot of
potential not sort of self-explanatory
you could say that for all H ones that
are not you know with the title class on
them
everything else is red someone asked me
like why wouldn't you want to use just
an ID and make a specific rule for that
and I don't know that's kind of up in
the air for me I gotta like think about
that one you know doing doing it this
way it means that instead of just using
like an ID imagine that you wanted to
have more things with this sort of
specificity of only targeting like we
were one element and then at least with
this one you can add like a list of
selectors to
and with an ID you don't necessarily
want to have like an entire you know
chain it kind of messes it kind of kind
of adds length to your CSS file and I'm
all for writing shorter shorter code the
less code you can write to do the same
job I think the better so then there's
the parent selector so this one actually
I had to think about philippics I
thought it's pretty interesting when I
saw it so there's there's actually an
exclamation mark in there which I'm not
sure is a really great use of notation
or not really great notation considering
we also use like the important tag I
mean ideally you don't use it very often
but we've got the exclamation mark with
the the important tag and so what's
happening in the first line there is
that using that that exclamation mark
after the li element it will select all
list elements that our parent to an
anchor tag that have the active class
applied so that's really useful for
styling navigation lists rather like it
because I can think of times where I'm
like okay I really want to select the
parent of this one but do I put the
active class on the LI or do I like move
that around and and I I like things to
make sense and be orderly and I feel
like this gives me more of an
opportunity to do that with like a
navigation menu and in the second
situation that one there says select any
parent of an input or an anchor tag and
so then you might change the background
for those I don't know that you'd want
to do that for both inputs and anchors
this is just some arbitrary example for
you to understand how it works so oh I'm
sorry that the blue text on that is hard
to read I should have changed that so
just just credits here there's a really
great article on Smashing Magazine
it's called sneak peek into the future
CSS selectors level four and that one
talks a little bit about the ones that
I've talked about and a few more and
also there is another article on CSS for
selectors um if you I haven't pushed
these up to github yet these slides but
if you follow me on twitter at Angelina
Magnum I will do that within the next 24
hours because come on guys there's a
party later so and so polyfills right
like yeah all this stuff is totally in
the future and I told you you can't use
it today but I want you to be interested
in what's coming and if you have
opinions on it share them and polyfills
you know give me give me giving you what
can I actually use sorry as far as my
research has taken me only selectors
level four are really polyfilled at all
and I've found them in it's hard to read
they're SEL is a tiny tiny selector
I very kind of like sizzle but they've
gone ahead and implemented I think all
of the level 4 selectors so if you feel
like you want to play with them
immediately then you can go and download
sell and and you can actually try that
out so this is also a poorly colored
link that says list of mistakes in the
design of CSS so when I was reading
through all of these documents as as one
does on my Friday nights I found this
document called list of mistakes in the
design of CSS that the CSS working group
has on their website and there are
things like border radius should have
been border corner a
vertical-align:middle should actually be
txt middle because it's not really in
the middle box sizing should be border
box by default table layout should just
be same so I really loved reading this
list and I wanted to include it because
I want you guys to be involved in shape
the web so that all of these things you
know like so this list stations short as
it is it's not a long list I mean I
thought of a few things that could make
it longer but we want it to be as short
as possible because we want a really
nice experience for developers we want
things to be nice and interoperable on
the web so I want you guys to consider
being involved in shaping the web like I
said reading the spec documents is often
dry but I can tell you that the color
commentary on these lists is not boring
feedback from everyday developers like
you is crucial from my participation on
these lists as somebody who's not
necessarily a w3c spec writer I can tell
you that sometimes I feel like the
people writing these things are a little
out of touch and I know that they're
writing for the programmers that are
going to code this in the browser but I
think that they need more feedback from
people like you and you can join the
wwww style mailing list that's specific
to CSS but if you're interested in other
things like we know Web Apps and and
other technologies that have to do with
the browser then there's lists for that
too
and then speak up don't be shy I know
you're gonna go there and you're gonna
think what I didn't be like oh man these
people are so smart they know so much
about the browser and that's that's fine
maybe you don't know about all the
implementation details of all the things
that are that are go into that but you
can still give them informed opinions
about what developers are using so
anyway that concludes my talk thank
very much I am Angelina Magnum on
Twitter and you can email me personally
about any of the things that you like in
the world at Angelina at mozilla.com
you
you